your Emmy acceptance speech was very
beautiful and in it you you paid tribute
to your late wife yes very powerful it
was uh yeah I mean I was not ready for
you know I honestly didn't think I was
gonna win and and so to go up there and
and especially when you're talking about
someone you know Michelle McNamara was
of all the people I've ever known
romantically personally professionally
she was that that demarcation of I was a
different better person having met her
and spent a life with her and she was
the reason that my comedy got better to
get me to the point where someone would
consider me for an Emmy so it was hard
to encapsulate that in a very quick
speak I mean she was that everyone I've
ever liked especially been with
romantically she was the one that and
and people have people that I've gone
out with have justifiably pulled the
ripcord on me like this guy's nuts and
she was like no I could I can work with
this I think and you know she kind of
stuck with me and and so it's just that
weird and then people ask me now like
hey so are you happy like with it and
obviously yes I'm happy to have won an
Emmy but it's very it's very abstract
because it's the flavor of happiness but
there's no calories or nutrition there I
was like I've case it's like it tastes
like it but there's nothing and again
I'm not putting down winning an Emmy or
anything like that but but like watching
a bad movie with her or fussing over
what we're gonna pack for our daughters
like we're gonna go on a trip on a plane
like that was happiness that that's what
it actually felt like for real you know
so for us I just feels like for a long
time I'm just gonna have the flavor of
happiness until I actually get to you
know and and luckily in a horrible way I
mean in a
you know I don't want to sound but but
it's like aside from my daughter
it's gonna be a long look I'll take any
silver lining I can out of this swamp
full of poison and I think the one is
that I will actually no real happiness
if I run into it again based on what I
experienced with her like I now have
this real living memory of that
you